can we talk a little bit about your
first appearance on conan as a stand-up
because that was your i mean you've been
on a million times and you became a a
guest a couch guest which is yeah a
level up but yeah your first time doing
stand-up on late night or no it was on
the tbs show yeah is that right yes um
what was that yeah that must have been
surreal was that your first late night
appearance or no no it wasn't my my
first lady appearance was actually leno
before conan came so it was real i was
24 but oh wow conan to me was like i
don't like doing things unless i'm at
like i would never try to like get in
because especially with conan it's like
i don't feel like i deserve to sit at
that table yet um and so i remember the
booker
jp working with me seeing me at
festivals wanting to get a set together
and i would just not get back to him
because i was just like i just don't
feel like i deserve it yet like i just
uh well then you don't want to get your
dream
gig and then have it not go well or
something and then you're just i don't
think i never ever thought i was gonna
ever i still don't you know like that's
the time where i kind of feel like an
imposter is just in that in the conan
environment because i just put it on
such a pedestal that
this is why i've been dodging even
getting to this part of the show where
you talk about my appearances because i
just feel like i i don't even want to
talk about it because
i realize that as soon as you get to it
i was like oh my god i why am i tensing
up yeah it's because i don't even like
to i don't watch my own stand-up i am
kind of embarrassed
even though i stand by it there are some
jokes i do that i really like love
that's right but there's something about
you're very good at it you should i know
i you'd like it i know i got you'd be a
fan
it's just it's so weird maybe you'd do
impressions of yourself yeah maybe i
would i expect other people to enjoy me
but i can't even watch it's just such an
ironic thing but um
that i remember jp telling me you know
when i did uh
a podcast with him saying like you were
the only comic that i like couldn't you
wouldn't get back to me like you
wouldn't you were like dodging my calls
because i just felt i'm not worthy you
know
i but i had my parents come out for it
when i finally booked it i
because they were just such an integral
part of
me loving conan and um i brought my
little um i had my dad fly into town
with my uh
you know in the year 2000 book that i
had from high school that i would
highlight the funniest
and i would
[Laughter]
i loved that book so much because it was
the first time that i had ever seen
jokes written where i could study them
and go i see why this is funny here's
yeah like i could really
treat jokes like math equations and i
you could go they are yeah they are and
that's what i love about them is you go
okay i know this element and this
element how do i make this how do i
connect these two and make it funny and
it's it's just so satisfying but i felt
like you look back at that that book and
all my notes in it in high school in
class and me and my friends you know
circling our favorites and you just kind
of see that start of
so you look at that and go that's
someone who likes to write jokes and
like i learned from that book yeah and
so he signed it and that was it's this
tattered copy it's just like oh that's
great and he was so nice to my family
and um yeah it was just what you know
one of those moments conan met your
parents back in the yeah
it was so nice and so right before the
pandemic i was on in the studio version
it was the last time i was on and it was
the week before everything shut down it
was one of the last things my mom said
conan was the last person she hugged
before ever like for years oh and so she
was like oh baby i gave him kova she was
so worried for weeks because it was that
time when we were kind of going into
hugs
we had a surprise for you tell mom he
was very very sick
um
so he yeah that was the last and he came
back again to hang out with my family
and i have these pictures my dad gets
tears in his my dad doesn't cry that
often except when the rockettes are
performing for some reason at the macy's
the only time totally normal and healthy
when you saw conan
like
being a fan of mine it like really we we
both feel the same way about kona and so
it really is just like this oh it's so
cute to see my dad like so nervous to
meet conan wanting to make a good
impression but with like tears in his
eyes he looks like he just has like an
eye problem because he's like not
indicating in any other way that he's
emotional but it's so cute
he's holding my little dog that i
brought so he just he's like i hate that
picture i'm holding this little dog and
i've got tears in my eyes i look so just
emasculated in front of conan but it's
such a it's just a picture i will
cherish forever is my dad like gazing at
conan adoringly and just being i love
that finally someone made conan look
more masculine
it was win-win for all concerns yes yes